that's it you got your degrees now I can
finally stepped out I've been waiting 16
long years for this moment when you have
your degrees and are safely launched
into the next stage of your lives as you
were graduating from kindergarten in
1997 the world around you is changing in
fundamental ways beavis and butt-head
was cancelled but South Park premiered
Titanic Jurassic Park and men in black
were all released in 1997 as was a new
special edition of the original Star
Wars trilogy re numbered episodes 4 5
and 6 as production was started on the
new episode 1 the Phantom Menace laying
the foundation for multiple 15-hour in
six minutes Star Wars marathons in the
next decade for all of you but some
things didn't change the florida marlins
won the World Series by beating my
Cleveland Indians in a travesty of a
seventh game when premier closer Jose
Mesa remember him blew the save in the
ninth-inning extending Cleveland's
futility and professional sports
championships which will reach 50 years
next year
Thank You Jose in 1997 the first Harry
Potter book was published in England
1997 seven also saw major advances in
technology Valley the Sheep the first
successfully cloned mammal was
introduced to the public that year ibm's
deep blue a chess-playing program based
on research at CMU just like Watson one
its patch against Grandmaster Garry
Kasparov and in a powerful statement
about the advance of Technology and its
ability to touch every corner of our
lives wheel of fortune unveiled a new
digital puzzle board replacing the old
mechanical one which had a bleeze serve
Anna and the rest of us for 22 years I
figured back in 1997 I had 16 years to
get ready for you the harry potter
southpark tech-savvy star wars men and
black generation i got busy a lot has
changed since 1997 as you made your way
through elementary school middle school
in high school in fact almost everything
about CMU has changed our undergraduate
programs allow for much more freedom of
movement between majors that bxa majors
just graduated and the huge increase in
second majors and minors are all
indicative of this we've seen major
expansions in our programs and the life
sciences with new departments centers
and faculty several areas in computing
information systems and energy research
have advanced in addition to our
traditionally highly ranked programs in
the arts business public policy computer
science and social sciences engineering
and the physical and natural sciences
our humanities programs have been
recognized with rankings that put them
alongside universities known for their
strength in the liberal arts I think
every carnegie mellon department in
school is stronger today than it was 16
years ago of course there have been
extensive physical changes on our campus
though for undergraduate students you'd
hardly know it because you think the
campus looked exactly this way the
moment you were born in the expansion
also of our global footprint now 215
campuses and programs in 14 countries
during this same period pittsburgh has
thrived hosting the g20 meetings of
heads of state during your first
semester and being named America's most
livable city a key to our city's
resurgence has been the partnership
between the University of Pittsburgh and
Carnegie Mellon and I pleased to have
this opportunity to thank Chancellor
Nordenberg for his great leadership at
Pitt and for initiating and sustaining
our partnership thank you Mark
and we are a more diverse and welcoming
place than we were 16 years ago the
numbers show this but equally important
is the campus climate and culture
there's more much more but to me what's
even more important is what hasn't
changed in these 16 years and that's our
core values as a university problem
solving hard work innovation and
collaboration these are well known to
you you may be sick of hearing about
them but these values have infused your
experience here and they will be
guideposts and important touchstones for
you throughout your lives the source for
some of these distinctive CMU values in
fact is our founder Andrew Carnegie
might seem strange to evoke a 19th
century man to respond to 21st century
challenges but Andrew Carnegie knew
something about change he rode the wave
of the Industrial Revolution more Abele
and skillfully than any other human
being of his time Carnegie had strong
views about the kinds of values that
people needed to thrive in the world he
saw around him and he put in place an
approach to education that's centered on
these values despite all the change our
universities undergone perhaps or
perhaps because of these changes these
values have endured I have to tell you
there's an almost life-size portrait of
Carnegie in the waiting room on the
sixth floor of Warner hall many of you
have seen it for the last 16 years as I
drove to campus every morning early in
the morning when it was still dark I
would stop at the intersection of forbes
and morewood warner hall was entirely
dark except for a spotlight that shines
on Carnegie's portrait believe it or not
he can see it from the street at Forbes
and
or would the first time I looked up and
noticed this I freaked out I mean it was
like oh my god that's Carnegie but
actually over the years it's become a
beacon for me it also is represented for
me the weight of my responsibility I can
almost hear Carnegie saying to me in a
heavy Scottish brogue of course don't
screw up laddie so it's Carnegie on my
shoulder so to speak let me expand a
little bit on these values starting with
a commitment to demonstrate practical
impact problem-solving Carnegie believed
that if technology was to make human
life better things had to be built
tested tried and improved applied design
engineering in the arts or at the core
of Carnegie's vision making things with
creativity and precision to solve an
important problem in the world or to
make life better or more beautiful today
the things that we make here have become
much more diverse of course but we share
that idealism about building a better
world and not just in theory the
corollary of this interest in realistic
problem-solving is that we recognize the
complex problems unfold within larger
context or systems rich problems have
rich and dynamic relationships to other
problems there are many examples of this
perhaps the most obvious is recognizing
the global nature of everything today
technology the economy the environment
even higher education itself there will
be no American or Chinese only solution
to climate change there is no point in
creating a communications technology
that works on one continent and nowhere
else because we all want to indeed need
to be connected Andrew Carnegie thought
globally as well in fact I think he'd be
thrilled to see how many of you
have come to CMU from outside the United
States and you'd be delighted to note
how many of this class are majoring in
international relations or global
studies we didn't have these majors
before 2009 and today they are among the
fastest-growing majors that we offer our
interest in practical problem-solving
value number one leads directly to
another CMU value for which we are
famous and that is hard work yeah
there's no magic how do I de to have
impact in this world just take our takes
hours of study thought and experiment
and then more study thought and
experiment I don't know that we really
work harder than other people but my
sense is that at CMU a lot of people
don't think of such work as a burden or
a chore most of the time this seems
strange if you see work and fun as
opposites but you don't have to think of
it that way CMU people are practical
idealist we want to get something done
that will make a difference in the world
and bringing that about is just what
we'd rather be doing spending 150 hours
trying to figure out how to shave a
fraction of a second off a buggies race
time that sounds like a good week does
there are dramatic music rehearsing for
some performance or another and artists
architects and designers to invest
amazing amounts of time in their
projects for CMU people just bring on a
tough or quirky problem and we'll have a
good time at the Student Leadership
celebration on friday student council
president will whiner put it well when
he said pursuing your passion and doing
it well is what characterizes CMU
students the reason we put in the hours
is related to the next value a desire to
try something new and to make a
difference in 2006 at this very podium
the university awarded honorary degree
to john hall our alumnus who had won the
nobel prize in physics in 2005 hall
summed up something he learned here at
carnegie mellon very well the Carnegie
way is always to be trying something new
he said we wake up every day it seemed
you trying to discover in the lab or the
studio in the classroom or in our
imaginations how to do things better or
differently
in this kind of environment there's no
such thing as failure there are only
experiments that don't go is expected
that teaches something and equip us to
try again people in start-up companies
call this pivoting changing your
business plan to adapt to what happens
because even the most careful plans will
often in fact usually be upended by the
unpredictable and the unexpected go
forth and pivot often one recent
manifestation of this try something new
value is an upsurge of interest in
entrepreneurship at CMU and Brian and
the and his what's the name of your
company again pay tango sorry it's
thinking PayPal which is actually a
compliment I guess pay tango is a great
example of what I'm talking about
there's been a dramatic increase in
interest in entrepreneurship on this
campus during and during my time as
president student in fact the interest
in this is just sort and the faculty
know that no will be at the tempura
schools don jones set of roger and
printer ship in a project olympus in the
school computer science they've created
imagined ative and multifaceted support
for these aspirations the last
distinctive CMU value is interconnected
with all of the others and that's a
commitment to collaboration with people
who know different things than you do we
owe this one largely to the late Erbert
Simon the Nobel Prize winning economist
and computer scientist Simon's broad
influence on this campus was founded on
a recognition that no single
disciplinary perspective can provide a
workable solution to the important
problems facing the world you can come
up with theoretical engineering ideas
that work beautifully on paper but
without factoring in economic and policy
constraints or the vagaries of human
behavior you will not see much
improvement in actual practice there are
people on this campus who like to work
alone and are brilliant at it and that's
fine
but most of us find more satisfaction
and success I'm working in teams we
collaborate often especially with people
who know things and who have skills that
we don't have that's the way it is here
and that's the way it will be whatever
comes next for you and you're prepared
for that collaboration and teamwork
acquired that we develop a certain
quality let's call it it confident
humility and I think Dean I thank Dean
of Student Affairs Gina castellino for
pointing this one out when you're part
of a team you have to be confident in
your own skills and knowledge I don't
mean empty bravado I mean the
recognition that you do have a solid
background that is important and
relevant to the task at hand and this
certainly one area where being a CMU
graduate serves you exceptionally well
but along with this confidence in your
own knowledge and skill comes the
humility from knowing that you don't
know everything you have to be open
enough to trust that your partners in
collaboration bring value to the job as
well especially for people who are smart
this could be a hard lesson but his
election lesson that you certainly have
learned here whether was in the
integrated product development courses
or designers engineers and marketers
work together or in the entertainment
technology centers teams of artists
actors and software designers or another
one of the many project courses we have
at CMU you've learned to respect how
other people think about the world these
values these four values have served
this university well and they will help
you no matter what path you follow when
you are motivated to innovate and to
solve real problems and your humble
enough to be open to other perspectives
and good at working together and you
have no problem putting in the effort
necessary to get the job done well
anything is possible
these values are the basis for CMU's
nimbleness our ability to move relevant
quickly when opportunities arise in to
excel in what we're doing and they were
the scaffold on which your education was
built they are admirable qualities which
you share with a special group in this
world the 92,000 people we have the
right to call themselves alumni of
Carnegie Mellon University the other day
that one of the many farewell events
held in our honor my wife Maureen said
something very wise another of the
countless times she's done this in our
46 years together she said it wasn't the
buildings or the programs or the events
that she would miss about Carnegie
Mellon it was the people students the
faculty the staff and the trustees or
drawn to this place people who exhibit
the very qualities I've been talking
about you people who are genuine
committed open smart and caring people
who live the values of Carnegie Mellon
it has been a privilege truly it has to
have served as your president to have
been the leader of a place so important
and admirable well I just can't say
thank you enough for that and thank you
to the class of 2013 for finally
graduating so i can now step aside and
hand the presidency off to subra i have
to say you've been a great class not
just my last the one I've been preparing
for all these 16 years but the best I
don't know if was the hog worth hogwarts
sensibility or the South Park irony or
the Star Wars epic heroism but you've
been fabulous
we're very proud of you thank you for
all that you've contributed to this
University thank you in advance for all
that you will do for the University in
the future congratulations
you